Fox News contributor
Georgetown University law professor
Jonathan Turley sir
um all right let's get your reaction
first to today
I think this is low hanging fruit
to me
um I think that this was forced upon
them we already know that they plan not
to charge them then they got the
sweetheart deal that got exposed by the
judge in Delaware this is plan C what
are your thoughts
well Sean it's conspicuous as you've
noted as chairman Comer noted as to what
was not charged you know they were
giving out Fair charges against Trump
officials uh with with great speed and
alacrity you know they hit Paul manafort
very quickly with a charge based on many
of the same facts what the media is
ignoring is that these uncharged crimes
do have one common possible motive when
you don't declare yourself a foreign
agent when you don't declare income when
you create these questionable
International transfers all of them are
does can be effectively succeed in
hiding that trail right if you declare
income you got to say where the income
came from if you declare yourself a
foreign agent you have to explain what
you're doing for foreign governments and
if you create this Labyrinth of accounts
to send money through different shell
companies and through different in Banks
it makes it harder for people to see
those transfers all of that fits a
unified theory of an influence peddling
scheme that did involve potential
criminal acts and so I think it's rather
obvious that the one outlier the gun
charge is the only thing that has been
charged now that may that we may see
charges down the road but these charges
were established in my view years ago
they could have made these charges years
ago and instead they're allowing some of
these charges to expire the tax charges
for example I were allowed to expire
even though according to these
whistleblowers the Department of Justice
had the ability to extend the statute of
limitations let's start with Joe Biden
lying let's talk about the phone calls
that he made to Hunter with his foreign
business partners the Cafe Milano
dinners with Russian oligarchs and
others
payments for for deals and professions
that Hunter had no experience in all the
shell corporations all the suspicious
activity reports tens of millions of
dollars I'd like to know what Hunter and
the grandchildren did for the money that
they were being paid nine by Biden
family members according to James Comer
um you know for all the talk that Joe
didn't know well the bribery statue
doesn't mandate that Joe benefited all
but it seems when he fired the
prosecutor in Ukraine that he was
enriching Hunter wasn't he as a result
of that firing which was against Obama
administration policy put in place in
October of 2015.
right and Sean that's what's so telling
about people saying let's not have any
further inquiry let's not do the
impeachment inquiry to see if any of
these are impeachable offenses it's an
act of willful blindness to ignore the
evidence that we now have why shouldn't
the public get these answers it doesn't
mean that the president's committed
impeachable offenses but I think that
anybody who is reasonable looking at
this evidence would say that there might
be impeachable conduct here there there
might be criminal conduct let me ask one
so this impeachment inquiry is necessary
for that what about barisma Joe bragging
leveraged a billion fired the prosecutor
we now know that it was an interagency
approval of the billion and Loan
guarantees as a result of that decision
to fire that prosecutor Hunter continued
to get paid for a job he had no
experience in Jonathan what do you call
that
right that's exactly it's a classic
influence peddling scheme and what
people constantly point out is that
influence peddling alone is not a crime
no it's it's not alone a crime but it is
often involves criminal acts to carry
out the influence peddling look this is
a corrupt city there's a lot of people
at this corrupt trough there's a lot of
people selling access but the bidens are
standouts they have always had a greater
appetite and that appetite has gotten
them into trouble I mean instead of
doing influence pedaling on a modest
level they went for tens of millions of
dollars it's also evident in a plea
bargain instead of just trying to get a
plea bargain they try to get everything
in that plea bargain Jonathan Turley
thank you as always hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else